it's appalling it's absolutely appalling
um and it has to be called out in the
strongest
possible terms and condemned i was there
at wembley last night i could see what
that meant
for the players losing i could see what
it meant for everybody in the ground and
everybody across
the country and this team have been
brilliant role models on and off the
pitch
they've had the courage to call out
racism and stand up for
equality and they've shown real
leadership
gareth southgate and the team have shown
real leadership and this is about
leadership
and i'm afraid the prime minister has
failed the test of leadership because
whatever he says today about racism he
had a
simple choice at the beginning of this
tournament in relation to the booing
of those that were taking the nay the
players that were taking the knee they
made it clear why they were taking
the knee the prime minister failed to
call that out
and the actions and inactions of leaders
have consequences so i'm afraid
the parameters words today ring hollow
so
how much personal responsibility do you
think he holds to this
leader's actions and leaders words and
leaders inactions
have consequences and the prime minister
had a very simple choice at the
beginning of the competition
did he call out the booing of the
players taking the knee and they were
clear we're standing against racism
the very thing we're discussing today
we're standing for equality
and the prime minister failed to call
out the booing so whatever he says today
rings hollow and like all football fans
i stand with rashford sancho and saka
today on this really important issue